so hi I'm attorney Jana and I'm working
at Warren research and developing
functionalities commercial learning and
I'm going to talk about some
functionalities that we recently added
to the world from language and that you
can use in a Mathematica 10 ok so
machine learning is a very broad field
we can say that basically anytime you
compute something from data you're doing
machine learning so what I'm going to
talk about is a bit more restricted it's
about teaching a program the task from
example or his task and this task could
be for example image recognition so for
example in this case classify if it's a
picture of face of a card or a face of a
dog it could be text classification so
classifying text by topics for example
so here it would be determining if a
text convey a positive sentiment or a
negative sentiment and more generally
prediction from from features so we're
going to predict a value with this
category called numerical from some
variables and here for example it's we
on a data set of persons predicting the
height as a function of the age and the
agenda ok
and for that we're using we develop two
functions that are called classify and
predict so classify deals with
predicting categorical values should
such as cat or dog you can say also our
classes while predicts deals with
predicting numerical values such as
breeding the ID as function of some
features ok so the key point about this
function is that they are automatic so
the usual process of machine learning it
requires a lot of expertise for example
you need to know about what model you
can use you need to know what kind of
purpose this thing you have to do in
order to use this model you need to know
how you will select the best I pepper up
a parameter of the model with some cross
validation techniques and then I'll to
select the best model
with some Croatian techniques or other
techniques and what we wanted to do is
to automatize all this process in order
for basically anybody to do machine
learning because we believe there's many
applications everywhere in your work but
unfortunately in that everybody can
knows how to use these techniques so
okay it's just some examples of what
pre-processing can be done so of course
feature extractions when you take a
feature like an image or text you need
to extract features from it so for
images to be numerical features for text
it might probably be tokens of the words
or I don't know some tiny sticks about
the characters or things like this input
missing data many time and we'll data
set you have missing values so there are
techniques to input this missing data
some time for some algorithms you have
to encode nominal variables as a vector
of numerical variables standardized
numeric variables do some dimensional
reduction when you see that the data
actually embedded in some lower
dimensional space there's some technique
to project onto that space and then you
make the algorithm faster and and
sometimes better or simply feature
selection well you see this feature
according to some information criterion
is irrelevant so you you don't use it
for for your prediction so the model
selection will be automatic as well
here's some example of models Zehra in
to classifying predicts so some you
might know some simple model that comes
from a statistics stress linear
regression is useful for predict and any
predictive value as with with the linear
combination of the features or each
aggravation that is for classifying
where this time it's still earning a
communal feature is to be the same as
linear regression but for for classify
but I wrapped in logistic functions to
make it a probability here you can see
the probability of distribution of each
class given the feature your very own
terms which has nearest neighbors where
in order to do a decision you look in
the feature space as example of your
data that are close in the feet in the
feature space
random forests which is a average of
decision tree
naive Bayes classifier and ok and so on
this one Markov model that is good for
text you know network is good for images
and those perfect to machine that you
might know that it's some kind of very
smart nearest neighbors and so all these
algorithms are better on some data than
others and depending the RAM are
features number of example or the type
of data so all of these there will be
eristic s-- to choose which model can
potentially perform well and some data
and then this model will compete with
each other with some cross-validation
technique it means that would be trained
on some training set testing and some
test set and the winner on the test set
or mini test that will be taken all
right and as all the things that I was
telling you before I per parameter
selection all these models a parameters
such as the number of neighbors four
nearest neighbors number of tree from
them forest and all of them as some
regularization parameters which is
parameters to prevent overfitting to
prevent I think a model that goes to
tress this red line and instead of in
the model that goes into this grid line
okay so all this is integrated to
classify and predict so how does that
work in practice so will show you for
example so so you just have to construct
a data set so here that I said there's
different format the simplest is just
the lists of examples so for example
this first example means when the
feature is one the value is one when the
feature is to the value is three and so
on and you just run predict around it
and it outputs a predictor function you
can see the method that it uses
interpreted the feature as numerical
that's good and then you can query this
function for given features so for
example if the feature is 2.5 what is
the prediction 4.25 so here it's some
kind of interpolation of of the data
same code for classify except that these
times the values to predict classes so
nominal values or categorical values so
we choose a functional integration and
again you can ask what do you think two
point three is I said two point three is
eh I mean I believe that 2.3 is less a
and so here is the same but with a set a
feature vector with two features so one
numeric all in one category call and
same again you can you can query what
does a classifier function think that
this feature vector is okay so let me
show you some example on some more
realistic data set so here I have the
data set of Titanic passengers where you
have for each passenger the class the
age the gender and if the died of
survived and so the goal will be to
predict if a passenger died of survived
given its feature and you notice that
some of them are missing and this won't
be a problem because there will be some
input missing and all the method will be
we understand how to deal missing values
so it just ran classified Titanic data
here the method is nearest neighbors
that I've been selected and then you can
query again if your first in first class
twenty years old female survived
third class fifty years old male
probably died but what's more
interesting is to ask about the
probabilities so this is something that
all classifier function have and
actually operate a function by this time
it will be distribution continued
distribution so it is probabilities so
it means like Oh a griffon are
probabilistic and this is important
because probabilities convey much richer
information that you can use for taking
decision afterward and putting in some
other whatever in your pipeline of okay
so so you can see here that the
probability so it's quite high if you're
twenty years old female in first class
and probability of surviving is quite
low in that case okay so I can look on
so the classifier information so the
information that I have about this
classifier was classified information
and so you have still the method a
number of class number of features
number of examples I've been used and
some specific parameters that have been
used that have been found by classify
such as a number of neighbors because
it's Kenya's neighbors the distance
unused thing like that you can also ask
I want to know what was your impression
of features of the type of features and
said I think the first one is nominal
use a class that's right
so can is numeric or it was the age the
third was a gender no me know also it's
right about it
so you can use it with that specify
anything but if you want if you a bit
more of an expert you can also specify
the method you say okay I know that we
see that I set to produce good result if
I use logistic regression so you will do
that with the option method and again
you see that the classifier change
there's some other hyper parameter that
are associated with this with this model
and in here I just plot the probability
that it founds for different value of
gender and class as function of age so
you can see that yeah being a female is
always better
yeah even male first class less chance
of okay okay so here is another example
this time using images so you have a
here data set composed of example of
unwritten digits okay it's an image and
you have to recognize what digit it was
these images okay so in order to to to
make it a bit faster because a 60-pound
an example i just do a random sample of
10,000 example and i also use the option
performance goal so this is actually the
higher level function you can use you
don't have to know about the models but
you can say I want a classifier that
will train fast with performance goal
training speed you could also say I want
a classifier which should actually
automatically okay that evaluates fast
when it's trained when I give new data
it will give the class very fast or I
want classifier that quality so so I
don't care about the speed or the
training speed or even the memory I just
want the best and you can ask you
testify already small in memory okay so
here we're going to ask training speed
and I'm running it
so you should take two seconds take a
random sample I'm just going to take the
image and 10 random sample and I'm going
to see this random sample what what's
the classifier believes so okay this one
you got all right all right you need to
do it again six-two six-three one okay
you got all right but I know it gets
wrong sometimes and and you might want
to know I always our friend oh good it
is for now it's one with it's a one rich
person but we just tried with 20
examples so you could put so to do that
you take your test set and you use the
function classifier measurements that
take as input the classifier and the
test set you run it and it outputs a
classifier measurement object okay so
the classifier was the nearest neighbors
there was 10,000 example in the test set
you also have some a few additional
information and then you can query this
classifier measurement object with a
property you want you can ask what was
what is the accuracy of this classifier
on this test set and it will say it's
95.7% here and another interesting thing
and it's actually the most useful one is
the confusion matrix so you can have to
plot the confusion matrix and it will
tell you for example here it will tell
you that there is five two that have
been classified as six okay it's a
matrix of give you user number of a
given class classified as another class
and actually let's take this one too as
six and I can query this time property
examples with two arrow six and I can
have all the example of two that I've
been classified as six and it can be
useful to understand what's wrong in
your classifier maybe maybe the example
were not good or maybe you need some
additional example that looks more like
that things like this okay so okay
here's a simple example another example
is about take just to show you the
you can use text as well so it will use
a Markov model of 302 0 I think so it's
a go to the Uni ground model for the one
we know a bit about NLP and then you can
ask what you think this thing was about
ok this was about cat what do you think
this text was about it was about dog and
things like this and ok here's another
example of a predict this time that
works on images what we'll try to do is
to predict the value of a gauge ok so we
have a data set of image of gauges with
a value there's 50 of them and I will
use predicts so it will output predictor
function with method nearest neighbors
the feature is image everything is right
and then I can ask what is the value of
the gauge of this gauge and the value is
0.75 and you can ask as with the
classifier function where you could ask
probabilities here you could ask was the
distribution so instead that it's a
normal distribution centered in 0.74
with this town elevation so it doesn't
say I'm sure it's this value we just say
this is my belief and you can use okay
and this is just a small animation with
dynamic where you can see so on the Left
it's it's a gauge that I set myself and
on the right it will be the prediction
of the predictor so you could see up
okay so you can see some small
differences there's only 50 example but
okay it gives you an idea and actually
this dynamic thing are really useful to
understand quickly what's in to your
classifier on your predictor function
neck for for debugging is quite quite
useful okay so there's another aspect of
classifying predict it's the built in
functions so I showed you how to create
a custom function with some data you
have but what we did is that internally
we trained many classifier and predictor
function and for some tasks that are
common
and and and that you would like to use
so instead of putting a training set
this time you will put just a name of
the building function so here it would
be the name language and it will switch
a classifier that classified text
according to the language so here what
it says for the house is blue translated
in in a mini language and and again I
like to use this dynamic thing where I
can type whatever and it gives you the
probability of the top languages so I
don't know if you have anything you want
to write anyway I mean so notebook is is
is a you will have two notebook so you
can play you can play with that if you
like okay so another one is a Facebook
topic so we trained it on Facebook
messages according to the topic to the
topic and and it what it says about a
new computer it's about technology
happy birthday special occasion this car
looks nice fashion and and you could ask
again for from the top probability so I
love carrots you say I don't know
foreign drinks 43% of chance for eight
Fitness 15% of chance maybe I don't
knows people who do fitness ate a lot of
carrots have no idea and okay so this is
a bit I mean this would be the toy
example but we plan to do a more generic
topic building classifier with probably
with some Araki of topic when you could
go as deep as you want in the inner
topics and I think this could be useful
okay this is a this time it's a booting
predictor function that predicts your
age assumption of your name so for
example if your name is Claire
you must be three years old
so of course of course it's not right
but what is it right about is a
distribution so so so I can do predicts
and adds the property distribution and
then I can visualize the distribution
and you see the distribution of age
given that the fact that your name is
clear which corresponds to the
distribution of people I mean the age of
people named Claire
probably in the us to conclude about
classifying predict so it's some simple
functions to do in some high-level
functions to do classification and
regression and so you can have custom
functions you can use built-in functions
and what we try to do is function that
simple that are automatic
so that really everybody can use and and
there are some success stories of people
that didn't know anything about machine
learning and and even after using it
they still don't know anything about
machine learning but but but I managed
Jen managed to make the project work
with that for example there was someone
was trying to to analyze how much how
much how much fire like the size of
fires in Australia and and she cut the
images the problem is that the grass
always looks different the fire after it
has been always looked different at some
rocks so she cut the images in mini
squares and she did a user interface to
quickly create a training set and then
she she build a pacifier and then it was
very well and she could the good
accuracy determines areas of the parties
that had been burned like like its
correspond to this party there's another
success story the other like it's
someone that is a engineer and it's
telling devices so it's control devices
there are many many options and
sometimes just fail and the client cold
and say why does it fail and also what
he wants it what can I change just a few
parameters so it doesn't fail anymore
and then you need an expert I read in
the books I mean it's it's all nightmare
to answer this question and and say okay
do that and still doesn't work do that
it's a doesn't work so what it did is
just you specify to constructive model
to try to predict if it will work on it
of course it's not perfect but it's
enough to give very educated
so you should do that and most of the
time it will I mean better than before
it could it could give a right answer
okay so I'm gonna stop with that if you
wanna know more
of course as documentation there's
there's a guide machine learning there's
some example in this new in ten things
and you should come to the workshop
speak quickly about the future what we
want to do so quickly so of course we
want to add more models one of them that
we're excited about is Gaussian
processes are very good for tiny data
set do supervised semi-supervised
learning it's when you have data when
the value is missing sometimes online
learning so when you want to extend your
classifier function operator function
with new data model combinations so the
ability to train yeah
to train two models on the same data and
then combine these two models and
actually on my development version that
I have here it should do it
so here if I put some text and some
image it will use two different model to
use a mock-up model for the text another
model for the image and then combine
both of them and something that this is
really exciting is is about implementing
convolutional neural network so you
might have heard of deep learning so
it's a model that are extremely good and
images but unfortunately they are very
slow to learn like you really have to be
an expert to learn that and actually to
automatize it's very hard we don't
manage to automatize this thing but what
we can do is train ourselves some
convolutional neural network and then if
you have an application of recognizing
so okay like here recognizing cat and
dogs you will use one of these pre
trained classifier actually you won't
even know about it you will it will the
convolutional neural network will start
from a pre train condition on your
network and then only the first few
layers will be trained in order to have
a very performance classifier function
and it doesn't take much time to train
and doesn't require millions of data so
it's something that can be quite
powerful and I think in the in the
following years we'll see many
applications using congressional network
to do image all kind of image
recognition there's also a few other
functions that I mean many other
functions want to do
multi-label classification prediction
recommender system function that would
probably be called recommend
segmentation tagging so for example
segmentation could be I don't know you
do an rating and you want to segment
each character or segment words in a in
a text thing like that well you could do
your own segment or or your own tagger
like you want to tag the part of speech
of a word for example this would be an
application of tagger using either macro
models or these kind of models and a
really nice function that my we don't
know the name yet but that will do
dispersion estimation when you give any
data any data set and you just learned
the distribution of this possibly many
variables data set and then you can
query can say what is the prevalence it
is there what is the marginal
distribution of this variable what is
the conditional distribution of these
variables and this can be a very nice